hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing the
Hogwarts Express and the UK national
rail network with a platform that's
invisible been accessible to Muggles and
a rail line that heads to a magical
School in the Scottish Highlands you
probably won't be surprised to hear me
say that the railway trip out to
Hogwarts is unusual to say the least
trains play a pivotal part in Harry
Potter with platform nine and three
quarters and the Hogwarts Express both
playing a crucial role in Harry's first
trip away from the dursleys and off into
the Wizarding World but have you ever
wondered how this magical Railway ride
fits into a pre-existing national rail
network the UK national rail network to
be specific does the Hogwarts Express
exist entirely independently from the
rest of these trains or does it share
some of the same tracks does it
transport some of the same passengers is
the Hogwarts Express able to magically
avoid collisions what gives from our
perspective it all starts at platform
nine and three quarters at King's cross
station where students board the
Hogwarts Express a Scarlet steam engine
transporting students to and from
Hogwarts the platform can be accessed by
walking straight through the barrier
between platforms 9 and 10. but you may
have a bit of a hard time if it's a you
will first go or B you're a muggle
Platform 9 and 3 courses was of course
filmed at King straw station on the edge
of Central London it's an active railway
station but at the real station you will
find that platforms 9 and 10 are
separated by tracks for filming
platforms 4 and 5 were renumbered nine
and ten and at the station today you'll
find the hidden access to Platform 9 and
3 quarters complete with half a luggage
cart disappearing into the wall once
you've made it past platform nine and
three quarters next you'll be boarding
the Hogwarts Express
the train runs between King's cross
station and hogsmeade station making the
trip approximately six times per year or
more if necessary it's only Hogwarts
expressed that Harry's relationship
begins to Blossom with the other two
members of the famous Trio Hermione
Granger and Ron Weasley once you finish
your journey on the train your next
destination as a new student is a school
that you may have heard of Hogwarts
School of Witchcraft and was a tree but
in order to answer the question of how
this Railway Network fits in with the
Muggle networks we need to dive deeper
into the history of the Hogwarts Express
Thanks to Pottermore we've got some
information that's not particularly well
known even to the bigger Harry Potter
fans when it occurred to the ministry
that transporting students to Hogwarts
needed to be addressed then Minister for
magic otoline gamble came up with a
solution a daring and controversial
solution to the thorny problem of
transporting students was finally
suggested by Minister for magic
arthelene gamble who was much intrigued
by muggle inventions and saw the
potential in trains where exactly the
Hogwarts Express came from has never
been conclusively proven although it is
a fact that there are secret records at
the ministry of magic detailing a mass
operation involving 167 memory charms
and the largest ever Mass concealment
charm performed in Britain the morning
after these alleged crimes a gleaming
Scarlet steam engine encourages
astounded The Villages of hogsmeade hoop
and also not realized they had a railway
station while several bemused muggle
Railway workers down in crew spent the
rest of the year grappling with the
uncomfortable feeling that they had
mislaid something important when
autoline gamble commandeered a muggle
train to serve as the new mode of
Transport for Hogwarts students she also
had constructed a small station in The
Wizarding Village of hogsmead a
necessary adjunct to the Train the
ministry of magic for felt strongly
however that to construct an additional
Wizarding station in the middle of
London would stretch even the Muggles
notorious determination not to notice
magic when it was exploding in front of
their faces it was eventually in
orpington Minister from 1849 to 1855 who
hit upon the solution of adding a
concealed platform at the newly muggle
built Kings Cross station which would be
accessible only to witches and wizards
with this brief bit of history on the
Hogwarts Express I suspect that it
either connects onto a muggle train line
shortly after departing from King's
Cross or it simply uses its own unique
line the entire way perhaps even it's a
bit of both to defend 0.1 it would make
perfect sense for witches and wizards to
utilize leverage the existing station's
infrastructure why construct an entire
Railway line when they can simply use
what's already there and cast somewhere
in the vicinity of 167 memory charms to
conceal the work done and Achieve said
alterations with this approach all the
ministry would need to do is create a
secret platform then produce some sort
of concealed Junction in a location
that's relatively inconspicuous and
nearby the train itself doesn't
particularly stick out or appear
inherently magical so there'd be no
reason for them not to use existing
railway lines as far as collisions with
other trains goes it just so happens
that the Hogwarts Express underwent
several magical modifications before
being approved by the ministry for
school use I hypothesize that these
modifications were put in place in order
to address this very issue but I could
also be way off the second point however
that the Hogwarts Express operates on
its own line entirely might actually
make more sense one of the main pieces
of rationale behind my support for this
theory is the fact that hogsmeade had
its own Station built under ottoline
Gamble's instruction
a necessary adjunct to the train from my
perspective there's absolutely no way
that the ministry of magic would chance
a Muckle Line's arrival in hogsmeade as
that would be a direct infringement on
the international statute of secrecy
which preserves The Divide Harmony
between muggle and magical worlds the
next argument for this second theory is
that no other trains are ever mentioned
running along the scenic route of the
Hogwarts Express it seems as though the
Hogwarts Express runs along an
exceptionally rural route passing by
seemingly very few cities and towns the
train rattled onwards speeding them out
into Open Country they made Regular
checks on the train as they flew further
and further north each step beneath the
cloud showing them a different view
London was soon far behind them replaced
by neat Queen fields which gave way in
turn to wide purplish Moors villagers
with tiny toy churches the great City
alive with cars like multi-colored ends
this route provided the omission of
information pertaining two cities is due
to a lack of cities contradicts existing
Northern Mughal routes out of King's
cross towards Scotland that in actuality
passed by many cities and towns
including Peterborough Durham Edinburgh
Etc the hokels express doesn't appear to
be on any sort of existing rail network
and I say this because no Railway
stations are ever mentioned on its
Journey with all of that said perhaps
the modifications to the Train by the
ministry mentioned earlier will focus
more towards concealment rather than
collision avoidance I'd imagine that a
lone Railway line heading towards a
magical school with no stops for that
matter would draw a considerable amount
of attention to stop any awkward
questions it would be easiest to just
make the train invisible to Michael's
eyes Q complex concealment charms to
construct the line which covers a lot of
ground I'd imagine that it would have
take taken an awful lot of careful
secretive work but for dire situations
when curious muggle eyes happen to
witness what was happening there's
always the 167 memory charms mentioned
earlier but I do have one more thing to
add in various shots in the films we see
the Hogwarts Express traveling across a
bridge a bridge that I happen to know
something about the bridge is known as
the glenfinnin viaduct found in Scotland
it's located on the west highland line
in glenfinen in Vanessa Scotland it is
the longest concrete Railway Bridge in
Scotland at 416 yards 380 meters and
crosses the river finen at a height of
100 feet the viaduct also overlooks The
glenfenin Monuments and the Waters of
lock Shield provided that we have visual
proof of the Hogwarts Express traveling
across a known bridge and not just
random Countryside evidence would
suggest that the Hogwarts Express does
indeed travel across some known railway
lines for that reason my final
conclusion is that the Hawkers Express
travels along a bit of both
whichever way you break it down
implementing a Wizarding transportation
system that's integrated with the Muggle
world is no easy feat the largest ever
Mass concealment charm being performed
is a testament to just how seriously
this matter was taken and sometimes I
just wonder why not flu powder and
that's it for this video if you enjoy
the content please like the video and
subscribe to the channel did you ever
wonder about this question until next
time remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live
foreign